99%做股票當充的人都實在不懂
投資市場遊戲規則
錯過許多賺錢的機會
今天不用9年的教學和產通的經驗
統整成一集100%新手必懂的
進線充的三大核心獲利邏輯
幫助你7分鐘快速搞得90%的人
最容易忽略的獲利核心關鍵
幫助你很很甩開
你與其他人的獲利差距
先來說明當充是什麼
背後核心的獲利邏輯
如果你要做股票當充
必須符合接下來四大步驟
規則
第部走
選擇相同的證券帳戶
像是台灣有
台新星光
群益
永豐金
等證券公司
可以到任何一家證券公司
開戶
假設今天選擇
台新星光
開完戶後
我們就擁有了
台新星光的股票交易帳戶
就可以住當中
再來
進入到第二部走
選擇相同的股票
選擇可以當充的股票
這邊假設
我們選擇
學把這間公司
這一檔股票
再來進入到最核心關鍵
第三部走
交易時間
台灣股票
開盤的時間從早上九點開始
到下午一點半結束交易
如果要做當充交易
必須要在九點到一點半
完成買賣交易
所以當充也叫做當日充銷
這邊要特別注意喔
新手不要拖到最後十分鐘採交易
避免當天無法完成當中
會多付額外的費用
接下來是90%新種
容易犯錯的
一時步驟
買賣相同的章數
我們可以看到學拔這張股票
目前股價的走勢變化
我們可以在這時候買進時章
這時候學把這檔股票
帳戶庫存會加10張
後續上漲之後
再賣掉10張學把股票
這時候台新星光帳戶的庫存
學把這檔股票
庫存變成零
手上就沒有股票了
這就完成了當充交易
這邊強力要提前
每次完成當充交易
都要檢查帳戶庫存的當充股票
庫存是不是為領長檢查
有沒有完成充交
以上的當充四大步驟規則
必須都要符合缺一不可
當充兩種交易方式
一 現股當中
簡單來說
當天用自己交易帳戶的現金
買進賣出同樣的股票和帳數
也就是新手最常用的方式
根據統計
台灣目前大概有2000多檔股票
要注意
可是每支股票都可以當中
像是我們在看盤軟體中
股票走勢圖附近
會有這樣標示
進現衝
意思就是
進一指做現股當中
也就無法做第一種現股當中
重點來了
10%極少數
有經驗聰明的投資教育人
會使用接下來
第二種 資券當沖
也是90%新手
最容易忽略的關鍵
資券當沖
猜看來解釋
是兩種不同的交易方式
分別是
融資當沖
融券當沖
第一種 融資當沖
其中的融
就是借的意思
而資代表是錢
融資的意思
就是我們可以跟
券商借錢買股票
所以融資當沖
簡單來說就是
跟券商借錢買股票
當天完成當沖交易
第二種 融券當沖
其中的券就是證券
這邊指的是股票
我們可以跟勸商借股票來賣
所以龍勸當充
簡單來說
就是跟勸商借股票來賣
當天完成當充交易
接下來今天的重點是
一啪呼之高手
我會告訴你
進線充核心
過曆三大路機
一大量的
限股當充的人會消失
一旦股票被列入
進線充
會大量減少
限股當充的人
這樣想追價
買股票的人會變少
交易量會大幅的下降
流動性會衰退
像是當大盤指數下跌
原本持有股票的人可能會賣出股票
很大的可能會讓股價更容易下跌
二 選擇進線沖
但還沒進儲治股的股票
儲治股減的來說
就是主管機關特別加強限制的股價
因為過去一段時間
上漲過熱波動太大
成交量異常
為了讓市長人靜人靜
會把它列為儲治股
像這樣會顯示進線沖儲治股
這種就不略不能做當沖
另外這種進線沖
還沒進儲治股的股票
才是我們要鎖定觀察的股票
這些股票最好需要符合兩大條件
有足夠的成交量
最好有至少1500張以上
可以使用資訊當中來放空
也就是勸商要有股票
可以借給你才能放空
接下來關鍵的來了
三選擇隔日充籌碼的票
投資市場上有一派的主力大戶
習慣做隔日充
也就是今天會買大量的股票
隔天太高會賣出股票
算取加長大多時候
賣出股票的力道
會大於買進股票的力道
很高機率會容易讓股價下跌
以上三種必須符合
才能提高勝率和獲利
大家注意
不是所有進線充股票都會跌
也不要一看到進線充就放空
一定要看是否有弱勢的環境和條件
才能夠決定是否進場
稍後會有實戰案例
做詳細的說明帶重點來到
如果你想要使用
獲利核心邏輯提高勝率
就必須要符合資券當中
四個重要的條件
一 開戶買三個月
從你人生第一次開帳戶
開始起算三個月
第二 最近一年
買賣成交達10筆以上
買一次算一筆
賣一次也算一筆喔
三 最近一年
買賣成交金額
達25萬元以上
從表中可以知道
當我們要開50萬額度
我們必須最近一年
要用50%的成交金額
也就是25萬成交金額
不需要財力證明
當今天要開100萬的額度
就需要50萬的成交金額
但要付上30萬的
財力證明
如果你想要快速達成以上條件
可以在下方留言
我想要了解
如果超過10個人留言
我覺得公布快速的方法
4 需開立股票信用戶
可以到開戶的券商
找營業員開立信用帳戶
信用戶可以讓我們有
融資、融券的資格
我們來看過曆的實戰案例
首先可以看到這檔股票
顯示禁憲蟲
而且不是處置股
是我們可以觀察的股票
再來看後續走勢
是否有出現放空的進場條件
放空簡單來說
就是高賣低買
賺取價差
如果要在102元進場放空
下單軟體要注意
一定要先選擇
龍券賣出
下跌到100元
如果要出場
一定要選擇
龍資買進
我們回來看走勢
這時候看到放空的關鍵條件
如果在143進場放空
下單軟體一定要先選擇
龍券賣出
後續的走勢下跌
想要在140獲利出場
下單軟體要先選擇
龍資買進
這樣就能夠得到3000元的價差
大家要注意 不要一看到進線充就直接作控
這其中有關鍵的選股技巧必須先學會
很多學員常常問
像剛剛的案例選出容易下跌的股票
搭配進線充如何找到最容易賺錢的時機
我直接跟你講結論
當充真正顧慮的房間時段
不是整天而是早上9點到10點
但長股的是也是90%的人賠最快的時段
我們特地辦了一場股票當充免費的線上歌聲
專門鎖定9點到10點這一小時
幫助你如何看穿早盤
阻力大戶的手法
精準選出高勝率的股票
再找到買賣的最佳時機
進而做到獲利率在
我把免費報名連結放在下方資訊欄
能夠幫助你看到獲利的機會
事實上我沒有很多的學員
我完全不懂股票
當從到每天每個月套成紮實的技巧
為自己價錢從2000到6000
甚至到3萬元
但每周明而有限
趕快去報名
對了
這邊不是推薦個股
處署教學性的分享
沒有買賣建議
也沒有100%的保證獲利技巧
要知道任何投資界有風險
需要評估自己的口袋身體
我是尉德
拜拜